Selena gets her star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame Diddy is not Diddy anymore
and Elton John surprises the heck out of
the Lion King on Broadway hello friends
this is the daily Denny coming to you
from New York City that's right I'm
gonna be in the Big Apple all week long
for so very exciting interviews which I
can't share just yet but trust you're
gonna think it love but I got cooking up
for you in the meantime we still got a
show to do
selena quintanilla received a posthumous
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame this
Saturday at one of the most epic
ceremonies I think I've ever seen fans
came in droves to see the late singer's
family honor her legacy and I hear
they've been lined up all weekend just
to get a glimpse of the star our very
own DJ bahar was there and spoke with
singing his brother mother and her
widowed husband for his pennis there are
times where it feels like you can pick
up the phone and call her you know or
you're gonna drive home and she's gonna
be there and then there's the moments
that you know it can be difficult it's
it catches me off guard like if I'm at a
restaurant or something and you know
we're having dinner and then they're
playing music and then all of a sudden
it's her song it comes on and then it's
like when I'm not prepared for it that
can be a little hard today I was happy
because my mom well held strong you know
I'm saying it was happy of it I can't
when I came I was in my room I kind of
got a knot in my throat because I can
spin my room I can see the Capitol tower
and I just was like man this is just
gonna be too overwhelming you know but
it was more for me of a proud moment it
was a proud moment I was I was a proud
brother if you had the opportunity to
say something to her today what would
you say just that I'm you know I'm proud
of her I'm proud of everything that she
has been able to accomplish I'll miss
her always miss her every day
I gotta say it's pretty amazing to see
Chris posing there with Salinas family
if you guys know there's story that you
know that Chris has actually been
estranged from the family since we're
passing we have more with Salinas family
and the Walk of Fame ceremony up at et
online.com but moving on to another
story that's trending right now Sean
Combs just when you got used to calling
him Diddy he's gone and changed his name
again
the man formerly known as Puff Daddy
puffy P Diddy and Diddy has changed his
name for a fifth time and shall now be
referred to as brother love you can't
make this stuff up you guys and in fact
love himself tweeted the announcement on
Saturday on his 48th birthday hey what's
up y'all I have some very serious
serious news I mean I didn't plan on
this and I decided I know it was risky I
knew it could come off as corny
to some people like yo I decided to
change my name to do I'm just I'm just
not who I am before
I'm something different so my new name
is love
aka brother love I will not be answering
the puffy Diddy Puff Daddy or any of my
other monitors but love or brother love
okay it's my birthday I feel good
God is the greatest I give all glory and
I thank my mom and dad yeah what is it
that is me just I'm so joyful for you
you know I'm having a great time just
just living my best night better they
say you know when you get into that
groove you know stay in that groove
and just you know be able to enjoy the
blessings of life thankfully for lawyers
these are just stage names and not
permanent name changes but I swear that
soon this guy's not gonna have a name at
all and he's just gonna be a sound refer
to him as boom all right speaking of
sound the folks over at the Lion King on
Broadway were treated to these sounds of
Sir Elton John that's right
the rocket man himself surprised the
Broadway musical which is celebrating 20
years on the Great White Way
he hit the stage with the cast for a
special performance of the circle of
life
[Music]
apply
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's still got it folks I was actually
with some original cast members and
alumni of The Lion King on Broadway in
honor of the 20th anniversary and we'll
have more of those interviews for you
guys on Friday until then ring the bell
on this playlist and don't miss the
mom's daily dedi we're just gonna still
be here and in fact I got to go because
I need a New York slice ie